- Well, I see an upright bass behind you
and I'm just curious, I mean,
can I convince you
to play just a little
something, maybe, or?
- Uh, yes, well you know,
I don't know if I have any basses nearby,
but if I did...
(clapping)
(both chuckling)
- Amazing!
- How about Blues in B flat?
- I love it!
(low strumming)
(tapping sound)
- [Kelly] Something is
moving your camera around.
It's awesome.
- Oh, that was my tapping
foot, sorry, ha ha ha!
(Kelly laughing)
I tell you what.
- It was like, tapping with
the beat, like moving...
You play so well!
Lester, at some point in life
when we can be within six feet
of each other, we gotta
do something together.
I wanna sing while you play bass!
- That's what I'm talking
about, I would love that.
You know, I always play my
basses, but I find it's like a...
It's become a ritual
now before my newscast,
I put on some music in
my little home office
and then I start jamming
and it kinda gets me in this
like, head space, to do
the news every night.
Thanks for asking.
(Lester chuckling)
- Yeah, no I love it!
Kyle, like I was tellin' you before,
my bass player is so amazing.
He'll go like, how you have
your upright bass back there,
he'll go, you know, from
different kind of basses
and it's just such a smooth sound...
- Oh, I love it!
- Few people know this, but actually,
they always think it's the drummer,
but it's the bass and the
drums that really hold down
the rhythm and everything of a set.
- [Lester] Yeah if you could
out the bass track, ya know,
you would realize how much a part of...
You don't often hear it consciously,
but man, you take it, you
remove it from the music
and everything changes.
- Yeah, and then it's like,
"Wait, where's the, where's beat
"and where's everything", yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's such a cool instrument.
It's so cool sounding too.
- [Kelly] It's a sexy instrument.